ostensibly we all want love but oddly
one of the hardest things to do is not
hold it against people when they do
actually turn around
and reciprocate our feelings it can be
immensely hard not to think that those
who offer us love are in some ways weak
mistaken needy Craven or just effective
it can feel a lot easier when love was
unrequited and our primary preoccupation
was a thrilling dread that the admired
person hadn't even noticed us but now
there's finally no doubt anymore it's
really clear they do like us and
something troubling has arisen we're
feeling a bit sick we're tempted to say
we got them wrong they can't be the
admirable people we thought they were
but the issue isn't really to do with
them at all it lies somewhere else
entirely in our relationship with
ourselves
their affection seems suspicious
incomprehensible and a touch repulsive
because at some level this isn't what
we're used to it doesn't tally with our
view of ourselves love can be hard to
receive when we're not fundamentally
convinced of our own love ability we
spend our time seeking out those who can
make us suffer in ways that feel
familiar and it becomes natural to
assume that a kind lover has missed
something and perhaps then to try to
behave in disgusting ways just to make
sure they understand we're really not
who they thought we were and that they
will therefore leave us in painful that
somehow psychologically gratifying ways
in short how could anyone be so great if
they have the bad taste to think well of
someone like us
but we have to allow ourselves to
entertain another option perhaps this
affection we're receiving is not a sign
that our kind lover is weak or wrong or
has no other options perhaps it's a sign
that they've seen something in US which
poignant ly and tragically we don't yet
quite see in ourselves and have never
been allowed to believe in by figures in
our past that we are deserving of love
there is hope in all this hope that we
can come to trust our lovers more than
we trust our own first nervous
self-destructive impulses we can
interpret their love not as a sign of
their delusion or weakness but as
evidence of an inherent love ability in
ourselves to which our past histories
have blinded us yet to which their love
and tenderness can now awaken us we
don't invariably have to hold it against
others when they see some point in us
[Music]
you